hey what's up guys my name is jonah
welcome back to my ray tracing series so
last time was a very exciting episode
because we actually drew something we
rendered this sphere using the power of
ray tracing if you haven't seen that
video yet i highly recommend you watch
it first link will be up there as well
as in the description below there were
quite a few kind of unanswered questions
in that video there was a lot more that
i wanted to show however we didn't get
the chance to explore everything that i
kind of wanted to so what we're gonna do
today is we're gonna dive even deeper
into what we did last time because you
guys were very excited about the depth
of the series and we're going to explore
a little bit more about what it actually
means to like cast a ray
like what how does that work it's quite
a difficult task to actually draw this
as a diagram and that's one of the
reasons why i didn't really want to
explain it last time today though what i
have in front of me is hazel we're going
to actually write some code here using
hazel the big version of hazel which you
guys can access on patreon.com
we're going to use hazel to visualize
these rays in 3d space and be able to
kind of interact with them and fly
around them which i think will be just a
much better way of explaining this than
obviously drawing it on paper now you
could also use something like unity to
visualize all of this stuff but we're
going to use hazel because it's actually
going to be a lot easier and faster to
work in hazel as you'll see now before
we get started i want to mention that
this video and this whole series
actually is sponsored by brilliant which
is an absolutely fantastic place to
learn all about the math that you'll
need to follow along with this series
it's so good that i've actually
personally been using it to revise some
of the calculus that we'll need for
later on in this series so i'm very
serious when i say that it is my
favorite place on the internet to learn
math the biggest thing i think that sets
brilliant apart from the rest of the
competition is the fact that all of
their courses are extremely engaging and
interactive they don't just try and
present you with information they get
you to engage and interact with it and
they also present things very visually i
mean we're literally going to spend
today talking about rays and presenting
them visually because i think it's just
such a good place to learn and brilliant
is full of that kind of stuff aside from
math they've also got plenty of courses
on various stem topics such as computer
science data structures actual practical
applied science you know that kind of
stuff and you can get started with
brilliant for free just go to my link in
the description below that's
brilliant.org the churno brilliant have
also been nice enough to offer the first
200 of my subscribers 20
off an annual membership if you sign up
using my link in the description below
huge thank you as always to brilliant
for sponsoring this video so without
further ado let's check out our setup
for today okay so what i've got over
here is hazel i've just made a new
project in hazel again if you want to
follow along with this you don't have to
use hazel even though i recommend that
you do you can use something like unity
and the process should be fairly similar
you should be able to replicate this
pretty much exactly inside our scene we
just have a basic skylight a camera and
an entity and the entity is hooked up to
this kind of ray tracing
series.mainscript class which is what
you see over here the plan here really
is we're going to implement some of the
code that we actually wrote last time so
this is in the last episode we had this
kind of pink sphere being rendered it
looks like it's kind of in 2d space but
as we'll see today it is in fact in 3d
space we'll see a bunch of extra
information about this which is really
cool we're basically going to kind of
recreate this setup but we're actually
going to draw like each ray as a line
because that's what we're doing we're
just essentially creating these lines
and then seeing where they intersect
certain defined geometries such as in
this case the sphere and this is exactly
what we talked about in episode 2 which
is where we covered all the math so now
we're going to see like how those lines
actually
exist in a 3d space so the first thing
that i want to kind of pay attention to
is obviously this render loop here
because this is the basis for the rays
that we cast this per pixel function is
just what we do to each ray to figure
out whether or not that ray actually
hits the sphere and then we respond in a
certain way in this case by returning a
color such as pink if it hits and just
black if it doesn't but this is kind of
the real meat of it because what we do
here is we go through every pixel in our
image and for each pixel
once per pixel we cast a ray we work out
a coordinate between negative one and
one and then we pass that into this per
pixel function to do the rest of the
calculations so this is kind of the rate
creation code so what i want to do back
here inside our kind of hazel setup is
basically the same thing like i just
want to basically grab this and then
i'll come over here and just paste it in
now obviously this is written in c plus
we'll translate this in a minute but the
idea is for each of these kind of pixels
for each of these rays that we cast i
want to physically draw a line inside
this kind of 3d space so how do we set
that up well first of all i mean final
image get with get high let's just set
some kind of arbitrary width and height
we'll start we'll start pretty kind of
sparse here i might make a width of 50
and you know what maybe we'll make the
height the same thing we didn't really
deal with aspect ratio last time we
probably will cover it today but for now
we can set a width of 50 and a height of
50 which will be two and a half thousand
rays that will actually cast here i'm
just going to translate the rest of this
into c sharp and into this kind of setup
that we have here okay and now we have
this coordinate we have this coordinate
which is supposed to be between zero and
one so i'm just going to make it a
vector 2 because that's hazel's vector 2
type and then replacing the width and
height with the width and high variables
we get this we can we can still multiply
it by 2 and subtract 1 as we did except
this time instead of just setting an
image data i'm actually going to use
hazel's debug renderer to draw a line so
what we're going to do is we're going to
draw a line from some kind of origin
point now if we go back to this ray
tracing setup you can see that our ray
origin
was 0 0 2 and our ray direction was that
coordinate x and y and a negative one so
let's copy this code as well and then
back over here i'll paste it and change
this to be a vector 3 and we're left
with this so we still have like a ray
origin and array direction
now i can actually put the ray origin
into like the starting point of the line
the ray direction will be like the
ending point of the line however a
direction by itself is a bit weird so
we'll kind of grab the origin and scale
it along the direction by some kind of
length now this length i'm just going to
declare up here this is like the
visualized length of our line it doesn't
really matter too much but this is going
to affect what we actually see obviously
when we render this so this will kind of
dictate the length of the line ray
direction isn't normalized so this
length is not going to be like you know
two meters in this case but it will be
some like arbitrary length and then
finally we need some kind of color so
i'm just going to pick
a nice magenta kind of pink color for
that line all right now if i build this
come back over here
hit play let's actually hide that scene
hierarchy panel and then i'll go back to
like the editor camera but in play mode
you can see we have a whole bunch of
rays now they're a little bit hard to
see i think what i might do is let's
just define like some kind of ray color
here and what i want to do
is i'll make it black and i'll set the
alpha to be like 0.5 or something
slightly transparent and then we can
just hit ctrl shift b and it will kind
of live recompile as you can see and we
have
all of our rays here let me just make
them full black here so it's a bit more
clear i'm also going to just set the
line width to be maybe like a bit
thicker like three or something
there we go so now you can kind of see
each ray now each of these rays is just
generated using of course this
coordinate it has like an origin which
obviously is over here which we've set
to be a zero zero and two and then we're
shooting them in this kind of negative
direction if we actually show the grid
here you can see that this is kind of
the origin of our 3d world we've stepped
back two units so two meters to get to
this point here because that's our
origin and then we're shooting the rays
kind of back in the direction that we
stepped back into if that makes sense
we're shooting them kind of backwards if
this was positive two obviously that's
the negative z axis and we're shooting
the rays that way now in the last
episode we were able to actually like
visualize the coordinates by simply
setting the pixel to be
the color of the coordinate we can do
the exact same thing here we can just
set the ray color to be coordinate now
we have actually done the times two
minus one thing here so i'm going to go
back to just coordinate times point five
plus point five for x and four y to get
into a zero to one space and then we can
just leave blue at zero ctrl shift b and
we'll change that to coordinate y and
you can see
we basically get the same result now
which is pretty cool we can kind of see
the bottom left corner of the image that
we used to see being black and then as
we go higher it gets more green as we go
more to the right it gets more red and
of course more to the right i'm kind of
referring to from the perspective
obviously of this right so if we if we
look at it this way this kind of matches
what we actually had in the previous
episode initially now the density of
this is obviously a bit um
sparse right so what i could do is
increase this to something like 500 by
500
and we get a solid image now performance
is going to be a little bit bad here
because we're drawing like 250 000 lines
but uh you can see that we get like a
solid image right so i will be using
like some slightly smaller numbers just
so that it
performs a little bit better like even
that's fine so overall i think this is a
really good way to visualize what we're
actually doing per pixel in the code
that we wrote last time and again making
this a little bit more sparse we'll make
things like a little bit easier to
understand i mean if i even set this to
like 20 which might be spot too sparse
here what we're doing is from the camera
which the moment is just like this fixed
kind of little point right in 3d space
that's what we've done we've set it to
be like the ray origin from there we're
kind of spitting out all of these rays
in in different directions which kind of
ends up being like one for every pixel
that we actually have on our screen and
as these lines kind of get sent out from
this point we test each one of these
lines to see whether or not they
actually intersect this sphere that
we've mathematically defined so let's go
ahead and add that functionality over
here i want to see that sphere that
we've actually created inside the code
last time so if we go back to our code
from last time we have this kind of
defined radius basically from here i'll
just copy all of the code and we'll use
that as like our starting point let's
make this a little bit bigger so what
i'm going to do is paste it into here i
guess we can drag the radius out
this will be like our our sphere radius
we're going to replace uh the dot
product into what hazel's api currently
looks like which is just vector three
dot dot over here over here and over
here you can see the code is generally
the same right so now we actually have
the redirection right and we have all of
this kind of worked out and we have a
valid discriminant now it's just about
what we want to do with the discriminant
right what do we want to do with the
information of whether or not we've hit
the sphere well what we're going to do
in this case is just change the ray
color so i'm actually going to make the
red color black as it is originally i'm
not going to set the right color to be
based on this coordinate anymore however
what i will do is just set that ray
color to be
pink just like we did for the sphere if
it actually hits the sphere so otherwise
we'll set it to be
black and if i hit ctrl shift b then you
can see back here in hazel now the kind
of lines in the middle here the rays in
the middle are all pink and if i
increase the amount of rays here let's
just move this over
if i increase this back to being like
200 by 200 then you can see we have that
sphere image just like we did in the
last episode but now we're kind of
drawing it with these lines and you can
see that if we fly into here actually
what i'll do is i'll i don't really like
the way this is set up let's just bring
this ray color down here we'll set the
ray color like initially to this black
value and then we'll just get rid of
this branch entirely i just want to make
it like slightly transparent maybe like
point two or something just so that we
can kind of see now this obviously
depends on the order that's drawn in
that's why we can't see everything but
you can see that we can we can still
kind of see through it um you can see
these rays kind of originate if i can go
slow enough these rays kind of originate
from obviously where all the rays
originate and then we just have these
kind of lines which go across and these
pink rays are the ones that end up
intersecting the sphere has nothing to
do with where they intersect the spheres
just did they or did they not that is
what the discriminant is telling us and
that is kind of that final image that we
get now what about aspect ratio what if
we didn't have like a one by one
viewport i guess well let's try and like
create something that's 16 by nine so
320 by 180 is a 16 by 9 aspect ratio if
i just rebuild it with that in the
beginning we get the same kind of result
but the distribution of rays is actually
different there's less race vertically
than there are horizontally the reason
why this is the same and we didn't get
like some stretch thing is because
obviously we're just drawing stuff based
on the rays that we shoot and they're
like this now in our original code when
we actually stretch the viewport
obviously now we're filling in colors
over a greater area
right that's not what's happening here
we're just mathematically shooting rays
so you can kind of see that if we adjust
this aspect ratio here like if i go
dramatic and make this like 18 then you
can see that there's just physically
less rays obviously vertically than
there are horizontally you can see all
of the individual kind of rays here but
vertically we only have 18. and then if
we kind of map that onto this area we
get a stretched image but the math you
can see isn't really stretched you're
just controlling how many rays you
actually send out so let's set this back
to 180 but to actually map this to a
larger area and for it not to be
stretched out here we basically just
need to take this x coordinate
and multiply it
with this aspect ratio so let's
calculate the aspect ratio that's just
going to be width divided by height i'll
just make that a float
and then we'll multiply x with aspect
ratio and now you can see let me just
close this now you can see move our code
out of the way now you can see that we
have like a wide screen view but this is
obviously still like a sphere it has not
been stretched and so if you apply the
same code to the code from last time
you'll get the same result okay cool so
this is looking pretty cool hopefully
this gives you guys just a deeper
understanding of how we actually shoot
these rays out now there are a lot of a
lot of problems from shooting out rays
from just a single point like this if
you're familiar with a camera frostum
you know there is such thing as like a
near clipping plane and essentially the
frosting you create is almost never like
one point for that reason we're not
going to stick to this kind of thing
forever we'll move to a more traditional
camera system which will have like a
near clipper far clip a field of view
that kind of stuff and that's going to
be really important because as we start
to kind of move this around if we were
to which we're not doing at the moment
the distortion is going to be not that
pleasant so with this current setup
let's go ahead and see if we can
actually figure out where these rays
intersect the sphere because now all
we're really drawing is whether or not a
ray intersects a sphere if it doesn't it
gets this kind of black color and if it
does it's pink but what about drawing
like a sphere in 3d space how does that
work well if we go back to our math from
episode 2 then we know that once we have
the discriminant worked out we can just
continue to complete the quadratic
formula to get our actual intersection
points and once we have the intersection
points we can feed them in to that
original ray equation to get like an x
and y coordinate in this case or an x y
and z coordinate in our 3d case so let's
go ahead and do that so we know that the
rest of the quadratic formula is minus b
and then plus minus the square root of
the discriminant which we already have
divided by 2a i'm just going to write
that down over here i probably should
get that like
latex plugin or whatever for for the
visual studio comments but anyway so we
have minus b plus minus square root of
discriminate divided by 2a so let's go
ahead and implement that we obviously
only need to do this if we know that the
discriminant is greater than zero
because otherwise we don't hit anything
and also we probably don't want to
square root a negative number so our t
value we're actually going to have two t
values i'll label one of them as t zero
because we have a plus minus here but t
0 is going to be minus b we'll make this
like the smaller one so we'll do minus
the square root of the discriminant
divided by 2 times a and i'll just put
this into parentheses as well that's
going to be our t0 that's like the minus
variance of this quadratic formula and
t1 is going to be the plus variance
we'll just change this to be a plus
those are our two solutions now we might
only have one solution that is
technically possible although pretty
rare because that will be like a a ray
exactly tangent to the actual sphere but
in that case these will be identical so
once we have these two things let's go
ahead and plug them into the original
equation which is ray origin plus ray
direction times length and this length
is going to be
t0 or t1 now these are both three
component vectors so therefore this is
really just a scalar along them and the
result we get is also going to be a
three component vector which is going to
be our hit position now we do need to
calculate this twice if we have two hit
positions i'm just going to go ahead and
put these in local scopes like this and
then for each of these intersections i
also want to draw something now i'm not
going to draw a line i'll draw this quad
billboard which is basically just a quad
that faces the camera at all times and
we're going to draw it at hit position
now we need some kind of size which i do
want to control so let's go ahead and
say
vector 2
quad size
we'll make it like 0.1 or something this
will be in meters and then
we'll paste in quad size and then we
need some kind of color so for now i'm
just going to write vector for sphere
color and we'll make it like i don't
know green maybe back to four zero one
zero one that's green we'll paste that
in and then i'll copy this and paste it
here as well okay let's hit ctrl shift b
and look at that we have a sphere looks
like uh that size is probably big let's
make it a bit smaller
okay this is cool so now we can see an
actual sphere i mean if i hide the line
rendering for a second then this is the
result like we've just drawn a sphere
and if i make this a little bit bigger
over here let's make it like 0.5 or
something i mean yeah you can see we
have a sphere and it's obviously in 3d
space now not in 2d space there's our
grid you can see also it obviously is to
scale and everything
we made the sphere have a radius of 0.5
each one of these grid cells is a 1 by 1
meter grid cell so you can see that the
radius is in fact 0.5 it is in fact
centered at the origin everything
obviously computes correctly as we would
expect but wait we can actually take
this further since we've actually got
all of the hit positions over here let's
see if we can apply some basic lighting
to this for that we need something
called a normal a normal is basically
like a directional vector that is going
to be that's actually bigger than i
intended
that's going to be perpendicular to a
surface so in other words in this case
if i just zoom in here and show you guys
a normal for like this area over here
would basically be a vector pointing
this way for something here it might be
pointing that way right it's like the
direction that that face
points so how can we figure that out
well in this case it's actually very
very easy because we obviously have like
the hit position like we know that it
hits here because we're drawing a quad
there and we also know the origin of the
sphere in this case it's actually just
the middle here which is zero zero zero
so what we can actually do is just
basically subtract like these two points
i mean subtracting zero is not going to
do anything but you will need to
subtract it just in case this isn't
literally centered at the origin of the
world if we subtract these two things so
if we take this like hit position and
then just do minus the origin of the
sphere we're going to get a vector
pointing this way and if we want we can
normalize it to get like an actual
direction but since we've kind of
created this vector you can see that if
we i mean it's just a direction so we
can move it anywhere but if we put it
here it is literally the normal and this
will work everywhere so it's very very
easy to actually calculate the normals
of a sphere as long as you like know
where you intersect it so let's kind of
put that into practice what i'm going to
do is actually make like an array out of
this first first of all just because i
don't want to have to do all of this
stuff twice so these are kind of our two
solutions and then i can just write a
for loop that goes through this stuff
i and hopefully that will give me the
same result so what i want to do is
calculate the normal now so the normal
is going to be as i mentioned the hit
position minus the origin now the sphere
origin right now is zero
right i don't really have to write this
obviously i'm going to anyway just so
that it makes sense in fact i'm going to
make it a variable called sphere origin
this is next level programming making
variables for absolutely no reason but
again it's just so that it actually
makes sense
sphere origin okay so we have that
sphere origin at zero and that's how we
calculate the normal now the next step
with normal is we're going to normalize
the normal and then what i want to do to
verify this is actually use the normal
as like the color for that specific quad
which represents the hit position so
what i'll do is for the color here i'm
just going to write new vector 4 normal
times 0.5 plus 0.5 so again i'm kind of
converting it into that 0 to 1 space
because otherwise it'll be between
negative 1 and 1 ultimately and we don't
want negative colors that'll just be
black that's boring and then we'll just
leave the alpha as one all right and if
we ctrl shift b that you can see we now
get our normals now it's a little bit
hard to see because i actually don't
remember where these rays are coming
from okay so they're coming from this
point over here which means that if we
look at this
you can see that we get beautiful
normals these colors just represent the
normal of each hit position of the
sphere so each intersection we're
drawing the normal as a color so with
these normals in mind how about we add
some lighting to our original sphere
color so what i'm going to do is simply
compute the dot product between this
normal and a light direction which i
haven't actually defined yet so let's go
ahead and define a direction for our
light
vector 3 light direction is going to be
let's make this like
maybe negative x negative 1 negative 1
on y as well because it's going down and
then maybe like one on zed um i'll then
take it and normalize it then we'll come
back here and we'll do negative light
direction because obviously we're trying
to if i go back to my little drawing
view which is pretty cool
you can see that for this what if our
light is like over here and it's coming
down we're obviously not trying to
compare the coming down vector which is
what light direction is with the normal
vector because you can see this this
comparison will give us this kind of
angle right we don't want that instead
what we want is we want to compare it
with a vector going towards the light
like that because that will give us a
more a more useful angle so the dot
product of these will actually give us
whether or not this is kind of facing
the light and if it is it'll be like
above zero the result of that dot
product it is again if you guys don't
know how any of this works math
brilliant click my link in description
below it's honestly brilliant anyway so
this will give us uh a more kind of a
more useful result that's why i'm
negating it to kind of invert it so
instead of going this way it's now going
that way
and i also don't really want it to go
below zero so we're just going to use a
max here to make sure that it doesn't go
below zero so it'll pick the maximum
between these two if this is negative
we'll just get zero so this is going to
be basically like our our light like
multiplier intensity whatever you want
to call it and so what we'll do is we'll
multiply this light
with
our original sphere color now i don't
really want to affect the alpha channel
though so let's just do light times
sphere color dot x y z and then we'll
obviously make a new vector four out of
it by the way if you use the z plus plus
and you're seeing this new keyboard
everywhere and you're freaking out don't
worry these are just structs and then
c-sharp structs will just be allocated
on the stack so these are most
definitely not heap allocations don't
worry um okay so we have light terms for
color xyz um and then obviously one uh
for the alpha so let's go ahead and
build that
and you can see now that we have some
pretty cool lighting and if i make the
size of these quads even bigger so like
maybe 0.3 or whatever you can see that
like check this out we've got a lit
sphere made out of like ultimately lines
and little quads that we've drawn in
hazel using seizure honestly i love this
stuff one more thing i want to show you
guys is if we make this a little bit
smaller here i'll bring back the
rays that we cast in the first place
because it may not have been immediately
evident here but if we make them a
little bit longer so again this is just
affecting the visualization
right if we make them a little bit
longer if i zoom into the right place
here you can hopefully see
that for each of these pink rays that
hits the sphere you can see how they
kind of pierce the quads that we're
drawing it's going right through the
middle of this quad because that's kind
of at the end of the day what we're
doing we're seeing which rays actually
hit this sphere and then where and we're
just drawing like a little quad in that
in that exact location and the rays
obviously kind of they can keep going i
mean we can define like a maximum and do
all that stuff but at the moment we're
just visualizing lines at an arbitrary
length so this isn't really that like
mathematical but in the case of this
sphere and everything you can see
hopefully how that's kind of working and
by the way if we chose to for example
not evaluate both solutions of the
quadratic equation so let's just say
um but we kind of just wanted this this
one over here and we just i mean i guess
i can just
set this to to 1.
um then you can see we only get half the
sphere
right we get this side and then if we
set this to be two and maybe set this to
one so we see the other side that's what
the other side looks like right so we
need to evaluate both of these in order
to actually get this kind of complete
sphere if we're interested in both sides
which you might be you might not be up
to you now the final thing that i want
to show is um and i could talk about
this stuff all day honestly and play
around with it i recommend you guys do i
might publish this code somewhere and
obviously if you've got hazel you can
just open this kind of ray tracing
series project that i've kind of created
but otherwise i'm sure you could easily
adapt this c sharp code to unity or
something like that if you want but i
want to show the effect of normalizing
the
direction
so ray direction dot normalize so what
happens if i normalize this radiation
because i mentioned it might be a good
idea to normalize it if you want
accurate hit distances stuff like that
but again you don't really need to
normalize it but what happens if we do
so if i build that what you might see
over here
and it can be a little bit hard to see
maybe what i'll do is i might make this
a bit sparser and also
where's the color i want to make the
color solid i'll just set it to look one
what's happening here as you can see is
down the middle the rays kind of reach
this point but as we get further up they
don't quite go as far well it's because
they actually do go exactly as far the
length of them is all one now it's it's
going to get scaled by this length so in
other words they're all of length 4
meters in this case if i put the grid on
you can see that the rays that go right
down the middle they terminate exactly
at this grid cell which is four
and if i just set the length to one so
we kind of essentially don't multiply it
by length or if i remove the length from
here then you'll see that they all kind
of get to just exactly one meter here
and then obviously the ones that are
diagonal they're also now one meter in
length that's why they don't get to the
very end here because otherwise that
would be greater than one meter in
length so that's the effect of
normalization now i saw a couple
comments last time i don't really want
to talk about this now i saw a couple
comments last time mentioning that if we
normalize the ray we don't really have
to do this a calculation because the dot
product of a unit vector with itself is
just going to be one so in other words
we can just label this as one and be
done with it as you can see we get the
same result now whilst true
we don't need to do that normalizing a
vector is a lot more expensive than just
calculating a dot product remember dot
product is just the multiplication of
each component and then summed up
whereas to get ray direction you need to
work out the magnitude of a vector and
that requires using a square root
there's division involved in that so the
performance actually ends up being a lot
worse i don't really want to talk about
optimization at this stage but just to
kind of show you guys what i'm talking
about if we go back to our original code
from the last episode of the ray tracing
series you can see over here that in
release mode my render time's around
three milliseconds if i just grab the
title bar you'll see maybe 3.3 3.1
something like that right if i change
this to be normalized
but then don't do this calculation let's
take a look at the effect on performance
look at that now it's four milliseconds
that's significantly slower it's like 30
slower so yes ultimately don't normalize
unless you really really have to because
just know that normalization
i mean it's not the most expensive thing
in the world but it's obviously more
expensive than a dot product and that's
why i'm kind of not doing it and you can
see in this case if i bring back uh
let's not make this as sparse and again
the rays are going obviously further we
see the complete sphere we're just not
visualizing them further than this point
here but ultimately when we look at
something like this you can see that
whether or not it's normalized or not so
if i just comment out this normalization
control shift b
it's
doesn't matter this field still looks
exactly the same all of our normals are
correctly calculated everything is fine
so in this case we actually don't need
to normalize it but in general regarding
optimization and stuff like that i'm not
writing this with optimization in mind
obviously if it gets to completely
ridiculous frame rates and like it's
very very slow i will have to do some of
that but ultimately
we'll we'll talk about optimization like
at the very end it's much more important
that you guys understand the math and as
you can see it's more than fast enough
at the stage that we're currently at but
in general regarding optimization and
like performance we'll get there don't
worry i don't want to kind of start off
with putting too much emphasis on that
because as you can see things are more
than fast enough at their current state
and it's much more important that you
guys understand the math
and make sure that like it's all written
out properly you understand it before
you start you know taking shortcuts and
trying to remove certain things or
whatever because in a lot of cases when
you're kind of presented with that final
optimized version it's so difficult to
see the original math in there that it
just looks like magic code and no one
knows how it works and that's bad and
that's obviously what i want to avoid
for this series but yeah i hope you guys
enjoyed this episode i wasn't exactly
planning to make this episode but i
thought that it would just be so cool to
visualize some of this stuff one of the
reasons why i actually made hazel in the
first place was because i wanted a nice
platform like this to be able to
visualize things and teach you guys so
hopefully you enjoyed this hopefully
there'll be some more episodes kind of
like this in the future as well next
time we're going to take the code that
we've kind of more or less written today
here put it back into our original kind
of ray tracing application and then
we'll be able to get into some seriously
exciting things thank you guys for
watching don't forget to hit the like
button below if you enjoyed this video
and also don't forget to check out
brilliant using my link in the
description below i will see you guys
next time goodbye
[Music]
you